all right so my talking points my notes
if you will
on how to keep her obsessed with you
because again that's really what the
point of this guy's post is I'm kind of
taking a few steps ahead of him and
saying this is what is going to be the
most useful because I think he's really
rushing into this all excited she's
special it's a big surprise that things
are going this well and basically saying
how do I not [__] this up and I'll tell
you how you don't [__] this up
so in no particular order I've got a
whole bunch of them on here and I'll go
through as many as I can in you know the
first 45 minutes or so before I start
taking questions but queue up if you
have a question
first thing first note I have is be
Irreplaceable
if you are her best option if you're a
hypergamous best option she looks at you
every day she says this guy is
unbelievable what a phenomenal dude I
couldn't possibly do any better other
men approach her she ignores them like
this is the ideal situation that you're
basically describing you want other guys
to be invisible and you want her to be
infatuated with you you need to be
Irreplaceable
if if she thinks that there's hundreds
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
of other guys out there that are better
than you or equivalent to you then
you're replaceable very easily so you
want to be an Irreplaceable object in
her life how do you do that
be the best version of yourself
right I'll talk about a lot of those
things that kind of fall into play and
sort of toe the line with that notion
but being a competent exceptional man if
you're average you're boring right you
know I've said this many times you can
do anything to women today except bore
them they hate that [__]
they don't like
um anything that's predictable
they like excitement it is what it is
again I'll get into more of those points
in a second
the other thing that I would say is
um some absence is very good for a
situation like this
um I think one of the big mistakes that
guys make
is they Rush right into let's be
together all of the time
hey what are you doing Monday night babe
cool you get together hey what are you
doing Tuesday babe cool you get together
by Wednesday Thursday
she's probably not that enthusiastic
about spending time because she was on
Monday
just being honest right so uh Dr Orion
taraban did a video called give her the
gift of your absence one of his older
ones and you know I had him on my
channel for a plane to win I totally
agree with it it's like you like absence
does make the heart grow fonder being
constantly available responding to her
text messages immediately when she says
jump you say how high when she says she
wants to see you tonight you're always
there to see her
um you you have to be somewhat distant
somewhat unavailable somewhat
um absent in her life I'll tell you this
right now I know very very few
married people that are exceptionally
happy or are in long-term relationships
that are exceptionally happy but the
common denominator in every single
long-term relate and I know lots lots of
married couples that have split up fight
hate each other call each other names
disparage each other sometimes in front
of each other sometimes but on their
backs I know lots of people that are
together that don't really like one
another the only ones that I know that
really like one another over a long
period of time like they are obsessed is
when they spend time apart so spending
time apart is good for the relationship
give her the gift of your absence you
know I've said this many times before
the most successful marriage that I know
is a good friend of mine who ended up
traveling a lot during the course of his
entrepreneur career
20 25 years
um was probably home around a week week
and a half tops a month and the rest of
the time he was busy with the business
uh that pursuit of Excellence that chase
of Excellence let her stay at home raise
the kids he did his thing with the
business and it worked out real well and
they're still infatuated with each other
25 30 years later now almost I think it
has actually been honest with you
because I know their kids are outside of
the University you get the point don't
always be around scarcity equals value
okay if you're around all the time
you're not scarce there's no value you
have to be somewhat scarce so consider
that
um be strong fit lethal
I don't know how many [__] times I
got to say this guys but I'm going to
keep saying it a lot of guys that ask me
for advice book me on consoles I see
them on Zoom calls I see them calling on
my shows but I'm a high value guy but
it's like yeah but you're fat
I'm just gonna say it look if you're not
in shape if you're not physically fit if
you've read my book which everybody
always starts I've read your book it's
been helpful blah blah then why don't
you have the 1.62 golden ratio why are
you asking me about [__] that doesn't
matter if I can see three Trends on you
okay
this seems so basic to me and it's
something that so many guys just
completely screw up entirely I had that
guy on a couple weeks ago the guy that
was an in cell five foot six 110 pounds
didn't didn't understand the importance
of a strong masculine frame about 110
pounds was acceptable
my chick weighs more than that like
being fit and strong and lethal to some
degree
are skills that are useful to you as you
navigate the world
um you're walking down the street and
I'm walking down the street and if
you're buck 10 five foot six and I'm six
two two fifteen to twenty or so and
there's a bad guy walking the other way
that likes to pick on somebody or
pickpockets or you know wants to steal a
watch he's gonna go for him not me
Being Fit strong and lethal matters
knowing how to fight is helpful having
some sort of combat skills is helpful
but at least don't look like a skinny
schlep or a fat pig get yours get get
your health in order it's not just for
women it's for you it's for your own
health later on down the road and for
your life just women happen to like that
okay you don't go for the bodybuilder
look swimmer's body that's it right like
look like Michael Phelps done you don't
have to be a bodybuilder chicks don't
even dig that to be honest with you
um
let's cover be a gentleman and an
[__] at the same time
it has to be said
women like a gentleman but they also
like an [__] hold the door open for
when she's all dressed up you're going
into the restaurant pull out her chair
sit her down help her put her jacket on
help her take her jacket off that kind
of stuff that a gentleman does
you can also be a little bit of an
[__] too there's an old saying in the
UK that I used to hear when I lived over
there
you know to keep her around you've got
to be a little bit mean to have her
being keen on you right if you want her
sweet on you you're gonna have to be
mean if you want her key
so don't be a nice guy
be a kind man be a gentleman but don't
be a nice guy don't be a pushover if you
want to know what that means there's a
book called No More Mr Nice Guy Dr
Robert Glover wrote it good read I've
recommend it a million times if you
haven't read it it's worth checking out
I make some references to it in my book
basically the tldr version of it is
don't be a nice guy but be a kind man
right if you want to dive down the
rabbit hole to understand what all that
means you can go do the work and read
that book
uh uh what should we do
let's do
the significance of captivation
so being like being significant matters
right
um look there's no way around it women
like significant guys they stick around
guys that are significant in the world
that are compelling uh that are
captivating
that have something going on
um you know I've talked about this
before there's loads of super successful
guys that have had two three exits and
you know by that like I mean like seven
eight figure exits out of their business
made a ton of money our retired
semi-retired sort of thing and they
become coaching clients because they
need help with you know the gals they
have a total weapon in the workforce in
their business and they do really well
and then you know you get into them are
like you know I just can't keep them
around it's like well you're tall you're
good looking you've got loads of money
uh you know you're not out of shape you
know you're in reasonable good shape so
what what's the problem like why well
they seem to get bored and leave okay
well that's a problem right right so the
notion of doing something of some
significance like even like
I had this conversation with with a
world-class athlete once okay I was
having lunch with him uh major league
baseball player
and he's telling me the story he's got
rings and everything you know from uh
World Series
um
inductee to the Hall of Fame I'm not a
big fan of baseball so I'm trying to
remember all the accolades but big ass
name like if I mention his name like he
would recognize him and dude's retired
career is done and he sits in on the
couch and he must take a nap and his
wife comes over and she starts chirping
him what are you doing I'm gonna take a
nap well you can't do that you know like
you've got to find something to do
basically is what she said he's like no
I've I've done what I need to do and I'm
going to take a nap right like that's
the component of having a frame in an
LTR but it's everybody that gets [__]
tested in that area even world-class
athletes will get [__] tested in that
area being significant and captivating
in your life throughout your life
matters you want to keep a woman around
you want to keep her in your frame the
frame component is a totally different
conversation but doing those things
keeps women interested in you if you're
predictable and do the same [__]
thing every single week of your life she
will get bored you will lose interest in
you and other things may become more
interesting to her I'm not saying she's
going to leave or she's going to bounce
but other things may or may not become
more interesting to her you spend
the same predictable schedule watching
basketball in a certain night and
watching college basketball the next
night watching football Cheeto dust is
all over your shirt you're packing on
weight you're not doing anything
significant with your life you're not
doing anything to improve it that's
going to suck being significant and
captivating you want to keep a check
around the dude's asking the question
you want to keep her obsessed with you
do some [__] with your life
I mean
I'd like to say it's as simple as that
but
those that understand understand right
because because they're doing it or they
have done it
let's go to F her properly now that
we're a few minutes into the video and
we can now talk a little more openly
because YouTube doesn't like certain
words in the first 10 minutes
I said it you have to effort properly
you can't do that
she ain't gonna stick around very long
she's gonna find it somewhere else
right you have to be
there's a really good scene in Devil's
Advocate uh Al Pacino is in that and if
you don't know Al Pacino that well he's
not a large man in stature I think he's
about five five or so and he makes a
statement you know his line is you know
something along the lines of he rocks
This Girl's World and he's talking about
the importance of rocking a gals World
effing her properly to his mentee
and in that scene he basically says
something along the lines of
you know she turns around and looks at
him after he's done like how did you do
that to me that's what you want a woman
to look at you like you know she's like
she's got to look at you like
wow holy [__] like I need to uh you know
give me a walking cane or something or
maybe I gotta call the municipal office
and get a uh temporary handicap parking
permit because I can barely walk this
week right like this is
like I said effort I'm not going to
explain it step by step because this is
YouTube uh guy by the name is Sterling
Cooper I've talked to him on my channel
a long time ago he has a course of that
kind of stuff
um I can't remember the author's name
but there's a book called sex god method
um
if you're already the Don you're not
going to learn anything from it but if
you don't know anything about effing her
properly read the sex god method it will
it fills in the gaps okay so I'll say
that
the next thing will be do not live
together now
this one is going to be very
controversial
I've thought about making a video about
this uh in my car talking about it in
length because this is kind of like the
sort of topic that I'd like to rap about
um I've been with my gal for a few years
now obviously and uh we're on uh
cohabitating long-term relationship you
know we've been dating for a long time
we don't live together
uh do women want to live with you after
a long time yeah they'll make requests
um you know the two smartest guys three
is it now three yeah about three three
of the smartest guys that I've seen that
I've had the most successful long-term
relationships
um that do well post divorce you know
into their 40s 50s and 60s sort of thing
like that they never lived with women
again these guys are divorce lawyers
they're smart
um they know how to keep a little bit of
distance they know how to keep a little
bit of uh scarcity in the equation
um they know that absence does in fact
make the heart grow fonder and they do
know that living together complicates
the relationship to some degree from a
legal perspective and also from a from
familiarity perspective big word to say
sometimes on video right but
if you become too familiar too common if
you become something that is always
around you will get bored you will get
bored you'll get bored of her and she'll
get bored of you uh the enthusiasm that
you have in the three-month Mark that
you're talking about over here
and again I mean in this guy's
particular you know scenario he's saying
uh we don't even ever want to have kids
in that case I don't see any reason why
you would ever want to co-mingle your
lives or live together at all
um I can't remember who said it but
somebody from the Nano swamp said
something along the lines of uh I want
to be married or I'd love to be married
again one day I'd love to throw a Log on
the Fire uh you know have a glass of
wine share a dinner and then you know
blah blah blah like all the other
romantic stuff love sex all that good
stuff and then I want to walk home down
the street to my house and go to bed
um and there's something to that having
a little bit of distance in a long-term
relationship and not living together I
personally think can be a great thing
you have to know how to manage women
will press you for it
um you know the response that I give is
like okay well you know take a look
around and show me a perfect example of
two people that have been living
together uh over a long period of time
that are that are still obsessed with
one another and they don't exist they
really don't
um there might be some examples made but
it's like you know if they have a
solution I'd like to hear about it
um I'd I'd love to hear somebody that's
been in a long-term relationship living
together over many years that is still
infatuated the only times that I've seen
that happen is when there's distance
when there's travel when there's
business interactions when there's other
obligations that take them apart from
one another so they're not on each
other's feet all the time
um women like I said uh that baseball
player once he retired and wanted to
take a nap on his couch wife didn't like
it what are you doing here why are you
taking a nap
what's this about right
a little bit of distance
is good A little bit of scarcity a
little bit of some of the strange is
good you know you want to keep her a
little bit obsessed with you right
um
other note I have here is putting a dent
in the universe are you doing it are you
you know serious question because if
you're all about her if you're
infatuated with her if it's like I've
had crushes felt infatuation I've
experienced sexual urges but this is
something completely different why don't
we spend time together it's always great
conversation great sex blah blah blah
okay but are you putting a dent in the
universe or is it all about her all the
time
um what are you doing with your life are
you doing something of significance
right what do you what is your purpose
what is your mission is it just her
because that's all I'm getting from
reading this right I don't know what it
is you know
when people fill out this form to
request a video
um let me put the banner out for that
one because I know that's gonna get one
where do I find that link Rich
um here it is
right there when people fill out that
form to request a video they do their
little email and then there's a section
at the bottom that says well link you
know like link your social so I can take
a look into your life this guy didn't
look at socials which tells me he
doesn't have a life to look into or it
could be that it's so private that he
doesn't want me to know about it either
way it doesn't matter because you guys
know that I've never breached anybody's
trust if you're making a request from me
to get some feedback on something you
know if you've watched my videos long
enough I've never ever ever and I will
never do it breach anybody's trust
knowingly or intentionally sharing their
social media anybody in the outside
world it's private I need to take a look
at it to see what you're about
maybe you got nothing going on there
maybe you want to keep it private I
don't know but I didn't get to you know
see any of that so I don't know what
what your purpose is I don't know what
you're doing with yourself I don't know
how significant you are how captivating
you are what's what's this Dent that
you're putting in the universe
another note here be attractive don't be
unattractive
so simple
who said that rhinestone
be attractive don't be unattractive be
good looking be compelling be
interesting be on some something
right be a guy that other women want to
be with and other men want to be that is
attractive don't be unattractive what
does that mean don't be fat don't be
lazy don't be incompetent uh don't be
broke don't have zero status in the
world you know like the opposite of that
obviously is all that that means
um
got a few other here let's let's deal
with these two
must know that she is replaceable so
you might think that's counter-intuitive
to the notion of obsession how do you
get a woman obsessed with you well I've
given you some good pointers but another
way to do it is so that she understands
that she can be replaced I'm not saying
that overtly state it
no that's not the show that's not how I
roll but it should be known
as a man of some action of purpose of
putting some dent in the universe of
some significance that again I'll go
back to it men want to be you women want
to be with you that you have options if
you don't have options if none of that
exists then you look pretty boring to
her you look like
you look like you are her only source of
intimacy potential intimacy at all so
don't be that right she has to know
covertly by way of your actions and your
lifestyle's choices that she can be
replaced don't go on and on you see
these dorks on social media
it's her birthday it's Valentine's Day
it's Mother's Day it's a wedding
anniversary and every single Frick and
post is the Dork praising her putting
her up on a pedestal I beat nothing
without you you're my blah blah blah
rainbow sunshines and butterflies my
stars my moon all this stuff
and the funny thing is when you click
through over to his social media or over
to her social media on like an
anniversary you know for example there's
no mention of him
it's her and her girlfriends with wine
glasses on the beach on her last girls
trip away and you know his is like
picture of the entire family you see
what I'm getting at here right like you
have to be a guy of some significance
you have to be of some competence of
some interest in the world uh the other
thing that really matters too is
she has to understand that she's got
first dibs to you but doesn't own you
so
I don't think that's anything that you
can communicate I mean you don't want to
you don't want to have to get to the
point where you have to communicate it
overtly
um anytime you have to get to an overt
statement like that
um you're not going to a good area you
know for being honest it just should be
understood that she has first dibs on
you but she doesn't own you if she feels
like she owns you like she can do wrong
and get away with it you're screwed
buddy you know you really are
um like she has to understand that that
that there could be consequences to bad
choices
um in that relationship and that you do
have options that you will exercise
other options uh a good example of that
is guys that end up in sexless marriages
or sexless long-term relationships you
see these all the time on these uh chat
forums and reddits and Facebook
discussion groups been married for seven
years we've been together for 10 years
we have sex like once every six months
when before we got together it was all
exciting and we would hang from the
chandelier and monkey section blah blah
blah
right
if she's if she's not exercising her
right to first dibs
foreign
remember she doesn't own it
you have to you have to make sure that
she understands that there that there
has to be work on her part to maintain
the relationship
um because women do
try to get comfortable and I don't think
they do this intentionally or get slow
or anything like that but they will try
comfort and some laziness in some regard
for a variety of reasons for example
um you're with a girl
whenever she's left your place in the
morning in the past she's always made
sure that the sink was empty and your
bed was made now months go by
that doesn't happen anymore
some guys will let that slide just be
like yeah I'll make my own batter I
don't even need to make my batter it's
okay I'll put in the dishwasher later on
but the acute guys the guys that are
unplugged that are really aware will say
something hey you know I actually chose
you like one of the reasons why I chose
you is because I noticed that you would
take the care of making my bed in the
morning you know before you would leave
and that and that matters to me like I
noticed that right
why would you stop that right like what
you did to get you in the door should
continue throughout the course of the
relationship you see what I'm saying
right I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out